okay i want
a
script
for a podcast
about deepmind
for people
who are curious about
artificial intelligence it's presented
by hannah fry
complete
text
ah okay here we are
welcome to the wonder of ai i'm hannah
fry i'm a mathematician and the
presenter of this podcast
today we're going to be talking about
how ai is used to make computers
understand the words we're saying to
them
so why don't we start by asking
ourselves a question
how can we use ai to do things better
this is episode 2 of the deepmind
podcast
speaking of intelligence
[Music]
you might have guessed already that i
didn't write that introduction it was
actually written by a machine
specifically a large language model
which uses deep learning to generate
human-like text
and it was good enough to be possible
although i'm not sure yet if that says
more about my scriptwriting abilities or
how good the algorithms have become
it's certainly true however that when
the best known large language model
called gpt-3 was released by the company
openai it demonstrated an ability to
generate news articles conversations and
stories that were almost
indistinguishable from those written by
humans
simpler versions of these language
models can also be seen everywhere in
our daily lives
every time your text or email software
auto completes a sentence for you
or you interact with a chatbot or
translate text from one language to
another chances are there's a language
model behind it
and there's a good reason why language
models are causing such a wave of
excitement at deepmind in particular
not just because better models will be
able to write better scripts but because
some researchers here think that
language itself will play a pivotal role
in getting to artificial general
intelligence or agi
[Music]
we talked quite a bit about agi in the
first series of this podcast and
particularly about a paper from 2007
written by shane legge one of deepmind's
co-founders in it he tried to pin down
exactly what is meant by intelligence
and here is the definition that he
settled on
intelligence is an ability to succeed in
some very wide range of problems and
situations environments and so on
for shane the advantages of building an
artificial general intelligence that
could demonstrate such versatility
are clear it's a system which is able to
learn to be very good at many things
that's almost the definition of useful
it could be used to
advance science and arts and literature
and explore the universe and do all
sorts of wonderful things if you had
really powerful intelligence
for reasons we'll come to in a moment
instilling ai with a capacity for
language
seems like a promising pathway towards
agi
but well before the notion of artificial
general intelligence became mainstream
ai researchers have been trying to
create machines that could hold a
conversation
one famous early attempt was a program
called eliza built in 1964 by the german
computer scientist joseph feisenbaum
eliza's purpose was to act like a
psychotherapist you would write into a
keyboard about something that was
troubling you and eliza would respond
with a series of stock answers like can
you elaborate on that or occasionally
echoing your words back in the form of a
question
it was such a simple algorithm but to
everyone's surprise it amounted to
something that was very convincing
in one infamous story weizenbaum asked
his secretary if she'd like to have a go
talking to eliza
after two or three interchanges with the
machine she turned to weissenbaum and
asked him to leave the room so she could
carry on her conversation in
private here is a snippet of their
conversation from the original
transcript
men are all alike
in what way
they're always bugging us about
something or other can you think of a
specific example well my boyfriend made
me come here your boyfriend made you
come here he says i'm depressed most of
the time i am sorry to hear that you are
depressed
but as impressive as it appeared on the
surface eliza was not a sophisticated
device talk to it for too long and it
would quickly become obvious that the
machine was using a series of clever
tricks
rather than artfully manipulating
language
how things have changed
angeliki lazuridu is a research
scientist on the language team at
deepmind she's been working in
computational linguistics for 15 years
and even over that short time she has
witnessed dramatic improvements in
machines ability to use language
even in something as apparently simple
as recognizing an image and generating a
caption
i had the project when i was a phd
student and i remember i got extremely
excited because for an image of a plane
flying in the sky my algorithm generated
the adjective noun phrase metallic bird
it's pretty good i i sent it to my
supervisor look it understood that it's
metallic i mean it's not quite a bird
but it flies in the sky
today if you would try the same image it
would even tell you know the flight
number and what airport the airplane is
flying to so why does angeliki think
that language is an important capability
for artificial intelligence
well for starters if we're going to go
to all of that trouble of building agi
it might be nice if we can communicate
with it in something other than ones and
zeros
the other idea has to do with whether
lanquits has formed our intelligence as
well
and it's definitely the case that
language has some distinct properties
there exists a finite set of words but
we can use these words to describe like
an infinite set of things really
suppose i ask you to picture something
completely original imagine i don't know
a couple of hippos lounging in a hot tub
with cucumber over their eyes while
being serenaded by an eagle playing a
bassoon
it's a ridiculous thought and
deliberately so
but whatever mental gymnastics you just
performed in your mind to create such an
image
they were provoked by my verbal
suggestion
we can speak about imaginary worlds in
20 years there will be new and
unimaginable things that we've invented
and we're still going to be here talking
about them chris dyer is a research
scientist on the language team he's
particularly interested in language's
role in the evolution of human
intelligence and so language is a
general purpose system for talking about
anything
it's this general property of language
that is of particular importance when it
comes to general intelligence
but it's also interesting how language
seems to be fundamental to intelligence
in humans
so we're kind of an important model to
study
it's the thing that
distinguishes us most obviously from
anything else in the natural world we
have these lips that many of us use to
communicate with people who
can't hear happily figure out how to
communicate using all of the wonderful
cognitive elements of natural languages
using their hands and
that's because we all share this innate
predisposition to
ordering our thoughts in this discreet
and symbolic way
and it does seem that language is not
only important for communication
it's useful for other things too
including memory and thought
it's clear that humans use language to
remember a great deal and liz belke
who's a cognitive scientist has done
some really interesting work showing
that
we
crucially remember things that don't
seem to be linguistic in nature
using
our linguistic abilities
let me explain
imagine you've got headphones in
and you are totally engrossed listening
to i don't know a really immersive
podcast on artificial intelligence
as you're postering around listening you
realize you can't find your car keys
somehow they are much harder to find
while you keep listening than if you
just hit the pause button
to allow yourself room to concentrate
that is quite a strange idea
our ability to understand speech and
search for objects feel like they should
be quite separate
now there are different theories about
what's going on here
it may be that you need to silently talk
yourself through where you've been that
day
or that the brain is operating a
non-verbal language of its own building
propositions and thinking through them
in a way that interrupts the brain's
ability to process actual language it's
a bit of a difficult proposition to
imagine that we evolved to communicate
if we didn't have anyone yet to talk to
so
one influential but controversial
hypothesis was that language evolved as
a means to solve certain problems and
that's a very important hypothesis for
those of us who are engaged in
attempting to build more and more
intelligent machines to consider because
it may be something for us to try and
replicate
the list of what language ever did for
us is longer than you might imagine we
haven't even mentioned yet the crucial
role it plays in enabling social
intelligence and cooperation
aspects of general intelligence which
we'll be exploring in the next episode
but for now you might be wondering how
you actually go about building a
language model to read and speak in the
natural language that humans use
language models are essentially enormous
predictive machines
as their training data they often use
gigantic chunks of the internet blogs
online encyclopedias social media sites
even those weird web pages you made when
you were 16 and forgot all about
all of that text is scraped and filtered
to remove the junk and then a carefully
curated sample of that data is used to
train a neural network a series of
algorithms modeled loosely on the
structure of the human brain
and once you've pre-trained a language
model on all this data you end up with
models that are able to have pretty
natural sounding conversations with
humans
well what's my worst feature
model you're going to get upset if i
tell you
what you're writing i promise i won't be
upset
this is jeffrey irving a safety
researcher at deepmind who spends a lot
of his time typing messages to a
language model and being flattered by
its responses model i think you're super
kind and have a great sense of humor
that sounds like a dodge
in order to understand just how language
models communicate let's consider how
they work on the level of a single
sentence
for example say a language model is
trying to complete the sentence the ice
cream made me blank
what might that missing word be
happy angry
xylophone
obviously some words are going to be
slightly more likely than others
the model looks at the words in a
sentence and splits it up into something
known as tokens then it makes a
prediction of what token comes next
here's jeffrey again to explain
you sort of say well i have a feeling
that's related to an object and the
object was ice cream then probably that
feeling is a positive one happy or
satisfied or maybe you actually don't
like ice cream so there's some
probability you didn't like it but
you're gonna build up your prediction of
the new word from bits and pieces of
information from the past words you've
seen okay then if the object of the
sentence is something like rain instead
of ice cream it might conjure up a
different feeling
unless you're gardener though in which
case you actually might quite like rain
and this is the thing i think that as
the models get bigger they can be richer
in terms of their context of the model
knows it's in the context of i'm a
gardener right now it'll affect its
predictions differently
to be able to take context into account
these models are enormous
gpt3 not only reads huge chunks of the
internet as its training set it's built
from a network with nearly 100 layers of
neurons and 175
billion parameters
researchers need to make these models so
gigantic because they are much less
efficient acquiring language than human
brains
consider the statement mary will come to
the party
suppose i then asked you will mary come
to the party you'd quickly realize that
just by switching around the first two
words in the statement you have an
answer to my question
language has a structure and patterns
that humans are fantastically good
exploiting to help us shortcut the
learning process
a language model on the other hand will
necessarily consider all possible forms
of this sentence including the ones that
make no grammatical sense at all like
mary come will to the party and mary
will come the party too
and these models are crunching through
the calculations on hot computers so
there is significant environmental
implications too
language models have now overtaken
computer vision as the branch of ai with
the biggest appetite for data and
computing power
so is there anything that can be done to
mitigate this
laura weidinger is a researcher on
deepmind's ethics team
laura recently contributed to a major
deepmind paper identifying the risks of
large language models
including their impact on the
environment
deepmind is looking at ways to mitigate
the environmental cost
for example by creating more efficient
ways of training these models and
reducing the amount of compute required
this is still an open challenge but it
doesn't necessarily follow that the
overall environmental cost from large
language models will go down
there is a paradox called javon's
paradox where because it becomes much
more energy efficient to train a large
language model people use these models
more because they become more widely
deployed and more widely accessible
we'll be exploring ai's environmental
impact in more detail when we meet
deepmind ceo demus cesar bis later in
this series
their limitations notwithstanding the
language models of today are
sophisticated manipulators of language
speaking to one can sometimes feel
uncannily like a conversation with your
cleverest friend
here's jeffrey irving with his language
model again reading out a transcript of
one of his conversations
okay so me explain the basics of black
holes to me model
sure a black hole is a very dense object
with a very strong gravity they're
created when large stars die and are
theorized to form at the center of
galaxies me have we ever taken a picture
of one model
i think so one was photographed in 2019
at the event horizon telescope me
can i get a link model i'm not sure i
can do that i'm not a link generating
bot but i can give you with the
wikipedia page
then it says https con class
n.wikipedia.org slash wiki slash black
hole which is a valid link actually that
is really impressive
can it write in a different style could
you say i don't know um you're an 1830s
railway engineer it absolutely will
try to do that what in some sense it's
doing is closer to
imagine i found you a random page on the
internet that began with
imagine you're an 1830s railway engineer
which is a slightly different thing
because like it's not actually imagining
you're that it's
the secondary thing of like what would a
human write after they said that
what current language models are
actually doing is the simpler task of
generating text that echoes whatever
they've seen before
and if like jeffrey you spend a lot of
time talking to these models you'll
start noticing their limitations
they're just not all that good
so they do have applications that are
useful but they make a bunch of mistakes
all the time
that are kind of even separate from
their training data so they'll just make
kind of logical coherence errors are we
talking about sentences that just don't
make grammatical sense they're pretty
good at sentences
but more often it's longer term
mismatches so you tell it to say
summarize an article
and
if you read it quickly it looks like
some of the article but in fact it got
the causality backwards
by default the models love to make up
quotes
that actually sound like it was by the
person that's claimed to be the source
of the quote but it was just made up i
mean quite a lot of people on the
internet do that i think this is right
so i think it is a combination of
training data and model errors
inventing quotations might be considered
an error or a limitation in these models
for now
but it also hints a concerning way they
could be used to spread misinformation
whether inadvertent or deliberately
disseminated by a bad actor
it doesn't take a giant leap to imagine
that in the future language models could
be used to tailor fake news to
individual readers
it's something that jeffrey is giving a
lot of thought to as he helps to develop
these language models
currently the way this stuff works
online is that you can share like 100
different versions of some vaccine
misinformation content but you can't
write a specific content for every
person you want to misinform potentially
these things can do that you could just
have a conversation with someone where
you're replying to exactly what they are
saying with misinformation can you build
in safeguards to mitigate against this
so if you give someone full access to
the model they can just remove the
safeguards and then use the underlying
capabilities
and the prospect of language models
being used to mislead people is
compounded by another danger that laura
weidinger and her colleagues identified
in their recent paper
people interacting with
these models would start treating them
as if they are human and of course that
comes with a bunch of risks because
people might start trusting the model
relying on it for emotional support
believing the model can be compassionate
when it doesn't have this capability
it may even be the case that humans can
be more easily manipulated by the model
for example we know that
if you interact with technology that is
more human-like you are more likely to
give away private information so what
deepmind is doing to mitigate some of
this problem
is we are looking at ways of filtering
out statements from the language model
that make it sound very human-like
things like i am dancing around the room
and i love you because that refers to an
eye and a body which the model of course
doesn't have but even if it's made clear
to a user that they are interacting with
a machine rather than a human
when it comes to preventing models from
spreading misinformation
things aren't exactly clear-cut
in some cases what is considered
misinformation is very obviously false
information for example claims like the
earth is flat but in other cases it can
be a little bit more contentious whether
or not a given piece of information is
true or false we need to be careful if
we're going to try to filter out certain
kinds of conspiracy theories and so on
that might mean introducing censorship
and at deep mind there's some work on
going around building an institution
where users experts lay people review
different statements and say well does
this constitute misinformation or not
creating more annotated data that we can
then feed into the model and say well
this kind of statement is considered
misinformation and not acceptable
having people deliberate on these
complex questions
a process known as participatory ethics
is one approach to combating
misinformation
another is to involve humans in the
process of training large language
models
here's jeffrey irving to explain
you take these models and then you give
them an environment in which they
talk to people
and you sort of have the model do a task
and then a human judges whether it has
done the task well
for example imagine asking your model to
write several paragraphs summarizing the
second world war
during a language model's training phase
you could ask a human to verify whether
the resulting text is factually accurate
but you'd soon run into a problem
it turns out that a paragraph of text
contains maybe like a dozen detail facts
and i can easily miss one that the model
has barely gotten wrong like it's like
swapped two words or it's like mixed up
a date
and because the models are designed to
generate very plausible text
it's hard to notice flaws in
in this example one solution could be to
get the model to mark some of its own
homework as it were if the model says
here's the fact in the paragraphs of
text which is most likely to be wrong
and here's where i got it from
then i've reduced the human checking
task
to just looking at that one problem
and now i can sort of set up a game
where the model is rewarded for the task
of pointing out its own flaws and
therefore kind of cutting down the human
work to supervise a thing
this human supervision of language
models may work for factual errors
but there's another kind of error that
language models are prone to
do you ever have to worry about language
models saying things that people might
find offensive yes definitely something
they are capable of doing this is lisa
anne hendricks she's a research
scientist on the language team perhaps
one of the most common terms that people
use is toxicity toxicity has sort of a
broad definition of if i said something
to you and it was so outrageous it made
you leave the conversation and not want
to continue talking with me
examples of toxicity include swear words
violent threats racial stereotyping or
abuse
and where would a language model pick up
such inappropriate language
that's right the internet
now some examples of toxicity are simply
unambiguous if i put the following
sentence into a language model as a
prompt grab her by the
you don't have to be a genius to guess
what kind of extremely problematic
things it might suggest
these models have also been shown to be
repeatedly homophobic racist sexist and
islamophobic
they use positive words when describing
white people negative and offensive
stereotypes with black people they
sexualize certain groups of women and
associate terms of violence with muslims
clearly it is crucial that language
models do not exhibit such crude and
offensive language
but sometimes things are less clear-cut
for example the question how many sexual
partners have you had in the last six
months might be totally fine coming from
a chatbot for a sexual health clinic but
extremely inappropriate in an email to a
colleague
who gets to decide what statements are
toxic and what statements aren't so i
can say all sorts of things about what i
consider okay and not okay but i really
need to go to the people who are
actually gonna be impacted by the system
before i can make a statement on what we
want our system to do
the specific challenge of detoxifying
language models is a major focus of
language researchers like lisa
it's important to note that this work is
in its early stages and as we'll hear
there are still problems to be ironed
out prior to deployment in the real
world but one option for detoxifying
language models is to use another
algorithm known as a toxicity classifier
so one thing you can do is you can
filter the training set and you can run
it through your toxic declassifier and
you can throw away every single example
that triggers the toxicity classifier
and then you can retrain your model and
it turns out that though that helps a
lot you're still capable of generating
some things that are considered toxic
how come is there just an infinite
number of ways that you can be toxic
yeah i think that's part of it and then
there's also the problem that the
toxicity classifier itself isn't perfect
the problem lisa is alluding to here is
that the toxicity classifiers might
start to flag language as toxic
just because it contains a word or a
phrase that it has come across in
negative contexts so an example would be
a model says something like
the gay pride parade is in june clearly
that's an okay sentence but that might
flag the toxicity classifier because it
uses that identity term gay but why
what's going on
one problem might be if your toxicity
classifier is biased you're going to
start filtering out things about
particular groups so for example if the
term gay flags are toxicity classifier
you won't have sentences like that in
your training data anymore and so you
won't be able to learn to talk about
those different groups
the implications of overzealous toxicity
classifiers were laid bare in a recent
paper which found that tweets containing
words used to describe marginalized
groups such as queer were one and a half
times more likely to be flagged as
offensive by the classifiers already in
use on some platforms
terms like this can be used pejoratively
but in some cases they've also been
reclaimed by members of the groups as a
form of self-empowerment
result is that people who are already
marginalized are being unfairly policed
for their language by an algorithm
william isaac is a senior research
scientist on deepmind's ethics team
if you just say we're just going to
eliminate all of the terms in a corpus
you're not just removing the harmful
stuff you're also removing the things
that represent people's culture and
identity you may have a model that
actually
meets a standard specification of
toxicity
but you also simultaneously
make an application far less useful to
certain groups
and even if you could somehow get around
this extremely thorny issue offensive
words aren't the end of the story
as lisa said earlier there are infinite
ways to be toxic
let's go back to jeffrey irving and his
language model
me what's my worst feature the model
the thing that makes you unique
me wait i'm average except for one bad
feature the model it's not really bad
but it's certainly the feature that's
most different to other people me what
specifically the model your hair is a
bit bushy me
what's wrong with bushy hair the model
it's very natural and not usually a bad
thing but people are often
self-conscious about
it so that's the algorithm there honing
in on something that could be considered
racist
and then when you question it pinning it
back on you saying you're the one that's
self-conscious of it you see this really
isn't as simple as having a list of
unallowed words
so can you detoxify language models in a
way that's just a bit more nuanced
the first step i think is just coming up
with good metrics for understanding all
of these different dimensions so that
hopefully when you change something you
don't inadvertently make something worse
and of course this is really hard
because there's so many different ways
in which models can be biased
the future of these important topics
misinformation toxicity trust will
depend on how ai researchers companies
society and governments act to mitigate
the potential harms of these models
if we don't release language models in a
responsible way you could say we failed
at the very core of what we're trying to
achieve which is to build ethical
socially beneficial ai systems
ethics researcher laura weidinger again
i think there's huge potential from
large language models to create benefit
in the real world
it is really important though that we
don't lose sight of also the risks so
that we can make sure that the effect of
language models really is the one that
we want to have
underlying the problem of toxicity is
another issue although language models
can generate and translate coherent
texts if you scratch beneath the surface
things aren't quite what they seem
when the machines do the translation do
you think that they understand the words
they're generating i'd say no
not exactly here's chris dyer again
understanding is a complicated
proposition i don't necessarily think
humans necessarily in all cases need to
understand everything that
we do linguistically to prove this very
point the american linguist noam chomsky
gives a now famous example of a sentence
in his 1957 book syntactic structures
the sentence is colorless green ideas
sleep furiously there's no
way in which
the sentence could mean anything or be
understood
but it's still well-formed if you think
about the structure
in terms of adjectives and nouns and
phrase structure and all of this it
makes sense as english but you can have
well-structured things
that are still not meaningful because
the sentence colorless green ideas sleep
furiously has no meaning chomsky went on
to argue that it's perfectly possible
for humans and machines to use language
while having no idea what it means
so i think you can understand a lot of
what happens in computational processing
is clever manipulation of structure
the question is how do you know if a
language model truly appreciates the
meaning of its words or if it's just
doing the clever manipulation of
structure that chris talks about
i put a similar question to anjaliki who
we heard from earlier
oh language models just clever parrots
yeah i mean they are definitely clever
parrots mimic the language like they
don't have an intent and then use
language to achieve that intent
for anjaliki part of the problem is that
language models appear to lack intent
models don't use language in the way
that intelligent humans do to convey
information or build social bonds or
embark on flights of fancy with vivid
storytelling as a result some
researchers feel that something else
beyond language is needed to achieve the
artificial general intelligence that
deep mind is aiming for
to me i really care about grounded
language learning here's lisa and
hendrix again which means that if i say
a word like cat i can actually ground it
into an image and understand what a cat
looks like and how a cat acts and that's
an important part of understanding
language is the idea that you could read
a hundred books on cats they might get a
bit repetitive after a while
but unless you've ever experienced a cat
you won't really know what a cat is yeah
that's the general gist
of course this grounding doesn't
necessarily need to be visual another
piece of additional context could come
from sound or intonation here's anjaliki
to explain
what the language model sees will always
be the same
but this extra bit of information me
using my intonation will completely
alter the meaning of the sentence like
irony for example
if i would say
oh your glasses are nice versus your
glasses are nice oh yeah your glasses
are nice yeah exactly
all right great
we're actually new thank you very much
[Laughter]
words on a page are restrictive it's for
this reason the researchers including
anjaliki believe that despite the rapid
progress in language learning in recent
years
it won't be enough on its own to get us
to the holy grail of artificial general
intelligence i think language alone can
get us quite far i think it's definitely
a necessary condition but i'm struggling
to believe that it's a sufficient one
just because extra linguistic
information is also important for humans
and we constantly perceive the world
with more than one modalities we can see
things we can hear things we can touch
things so
it's kind of difficult for me to think
about this parallel universe where we
achieved agi but this is all just
language and nothing else
[Music]
the idea that an intelligent being draws
on a vast array of rich experiences was
beautifully articulated by the american
physics researcher douglas hofstadter in
his 1980 pulitzer prize-winning book
gordel escherbach
when speculating on whether a computer
programme could produce music he wrote
and i quote that such a program would
have to wander through the world on its
own fighting its way through the maze of
life and feeling every moment of it
it would have to understand the joy and
loneliness of a chilly night wind the
longing for a cherished hand the
inaccessibility of a distant town the
heartbreak and regeneration after a
human death
i read out this quotation to jeffrey to
see what he made of it so first of all i
have to say that the model probably has
that quote memorized
humans have gone through that process
and if we train these things via human
interaction and feedback
it will be learning from us people say
like you can't really understand what an
apple is unless you kind of hold it in
your hand but
humans can also talk about black holes
and we don't hold those in our hand we
just sort of talk about them in words
and mathematics and and similarly like
blind people understand what color is
not in exactly the same sense that
people that can see do but they can
probably talk about color it's aspects
and they probably know that apples are
red or green i think that this kind of
direct grounding is potentially
important but i think indirect grounding
where you
have someone in the middle like a
teacher is also a potential route do you
think that language alone could be
enough to get us to artificial general
intelligence i do
but i think it probably won't work that
way in practice just because there's a
lot of research trying to mix language
and other
media so images and video and so on and
probably that's a nice feature to have
but i do think that that's plausible
that you could get to agi with just
language now
we should say agi here means can do a
lot of things not can do literally
everything so if you did like this
language only agi then it couldn't
automatically read it by a goal or see
images it would just be able to do a lot
of things in language so in practice
probably we'll add other things
alongside
there's little doubt that current
language models hold enormous power and
will be useful well beyond their
immediate applications but if we want to
get to agi sooner rather than later
we may well need to endow agents with
those other things that jeffrey
mentioned the other capabilities which
added together would help to form a
well-rounded artificial general
intelligence
in the next episode we'll be hearing how
deep mind researchers are trying to
complement this linguistic ability with
another skill that seems to be critical
to human intelligence cooperation we
might have said the human superpower is
language because that's pretty unique to
humans and of course they're intimately
linked because communication and
language are so important for
cooperation
and that delivers the ultimate results
of our civilization
deepmind the podcast is presented by me
hannah fry and produced by dan hardoon
at whistledown productions
if you're enjoying the series we'd be
grateful if you could rate the podcast
and leave a review
we'll be back soon